Aaaaah, vous l'avez tant attendue celle-là !
Allez ! On part sur trois histoires d'horreur ! Ça fait longtemps ! (rire machiavélique)
Aujourd'hui trois histoires avec des mécaniques différentes comme d'hab
et y'en a UNE d'entre elles particulièrement
La dernière, la dernière parce que comme ça
Vous regardez la vidéo jusqu'au bout et je suis bien référencé
(rires) elle est HORRIBLE
Genre je me dis : si ça se trouve ça m' est arrivé
et je me suis pas rendu compte. C'est HORRIBLE.
Mais on commence avec la première histoire qui est l'histoire de Martin
*Musique de suspense*
Contextualisation, Martin vit seul,
dans un appartement au rez-de -chaussée d'un quartier qu'il indique être pas ouf,
pas très bien fréquenté. Appartenant au rez-de-chaussée,
la fenêtre de sa chambre menait sur une ruelle et à quelques mètres de
la ruelle, il y avait des poubelles et souvent il y avait des homeless qui venaient
faire les poubelles. Alors c'est pas une histoire sur la durée
qui a duré plusieurs semaines ou quoi. Non, là c'est un one shot !
C'est ça qui m'angoisse, c'est que ça peut vraiment tomber
sur la gueule à tous, tous ceux qui vivent au rez-de-chaussée.
Pas moi, moi je suis tranquille!
Un matin un peu avant l'aube
il fait encore nuit, Martin se réveille et il entend
*toc toc toc*  toquer à la fenêtre
Horrible, horrible situation.
Martin spécifie que quand ça toque à la fenêtre,
il est dos à celle-ci, il est pas face à celle-ci
et ce détail a son importance. Pourquoi ?
Parce que les stores de Martin étaient usés, genre il manquait...
Vous savez c'est des stores, ben exactement comme ça, où il manquait
des lattes. Quand il manque une latte...
Waaah je viens de vous sortir de l'ambiance. ohoh (rires)
Quand il manque une latte, en gros, ça fait un écart, tu vois,
quand même assez considérable.
Ce détail a son importance puisque Martin dit que si
quelqu'un a vraiment toqué à sa fenêtre, ça veut dire qu'il peut voir Martin
Donc Martin agit en conséquence.
Il est trop malin, déjà il est trop malin, c'est abusé.
Il explique que le son a été bref genre il y a eu 5 à 6
tocs à sa fenêtre. Après avoir passé
plusieurs secondes à être paralysé dans son lit
et à se demander ce que c'était que ça. Il y a, de nouveau, des tocs
*toc toc* Et à partir de là, Martin
il comprend qu'il y a quelqu'un, probablement
qui le regardait dormir à travers sa fenêtre et
qui a décidé, on ne sait pas pourquoi,
d'un coup, de toquer. Clairement si c'était un pote à Martin
ou quelqu'un de sa famille ou quoi, tu t'amuses pas à toquer
à la fenêtre, c'est nul, tu vas juste toquer
à la porte d'entrée comme tout le monde.
Et à ce moment-là, Martin a un bon instinct, il se dit: "faut pas
que je me retourne parce que la personne qui a toqué
c'est ce qu'elle attend de moi : que je me retourne et que je la regarde
et à partir de là, je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer". Donc il ne se retourne pas,
Il est très malin, c'est ouf. Il va, à la place,
juste, s’asseoir, tout doucement, sur son lit
toujours dos à la fenêtre comme si
il venait de se réveiller et qu'il avait la tête un peu dans le cul.
Et il va se lever et se diriger vers sa salle de bain,
qui est donc en dehors de sa chambre,
ce qui est totalement crédible, la plupart des gens se réveillent
une ou plusieurs fois la nuit pour aller aux toilettes
Et du coup, lui, il va jouer ce truc là. À partir de là,
il est hors de la vue du mec qui est à la fenêtre, puisqu'il
est hors de la chambre et il se précipite sur son téléphone pour
appeler le 911, la police aux États-Unis.
et il fonce vers sa porte d'entrée pour s'assurer
qu'elle est bien fermée, de manière à être sûr que le gars
qui a toqué à la fenêtre ne puisse pas rentrer dans l'appartement
À partir de là, Martin, il comprend qu'il a deux possibilités: soit il reste enfermé dans son appartement
et la personne n'arrive pas à entrer, soit il prend la fuite
donc il sort de son appartement et il tape le sprint de sa vie,
sauf qu'il est pas sûr de courir plus vite que son assaillant
Et il a pas le temps de prendre une décision, que LÀ
méga badant, il entend la fenêtre
de sa chambre s'ouvrir, le mec a réussi à l'ouvrir
(rires)
C'est terrible
Mais, énorme coup de chance,
Il entend son voisin du dessus
Mike qui descend ses escaliers
Martin déverrouille sa porte d'entrée, il l'ouvre de quelques centimètres et
il demande à Mike de venir l'aider car il y a un truc bizarre qui se passe
Il précise que Mike c'est un bonhomme : le mec il est très grand, très large,
Il avait entendu dire qu'il avait, en plus, fait des arts martiaux, etc...
Donc il est assez en confiance à l'idée que Mike vienne l'aider
Mike, le gars sûr, descend, se précipite à l'arrière de l'appartement au niveau de la fenêtre de sa chambre
qui mène sur la ruelle, donc là où il y a le possible intrus !
Et au bout de quelques secondes, il entend un mec se faire plaquer contre un mur
et se faire jeter dans des buissons.
Bonne nouvelle ! C'est pas Mike !
C'est l'intrus ! Il y avait bel et bien un mec qui avait ouvert la fenêtre et qui allait rentrer dans la chambre
de Martin, sauf que Mike est intervenu, il l'a empêché d'entrer dans l'appart,
et plusieurs secondes après tout ce bordel, il y a Mike qui revient, qui lui dit :
T'inquiète pas mec, tu vas pas le revoir de sitôt ! (rires)
La mauvaise nouvelle, c'est que le mec a réussi à s’échapper
et que c'était pas du tout une personne sans abri qui venait dans la ruelle pour
checker s'il y avait pas des trucs a récupérer dans les poubelles, ou des trucs à récupérer chez Martin.
Ce qui est badant, ça veux dire que le gars il était pas là pour la survie, il était là dans un autre but.
On ne sait pas lequel.
Mike précise qu'il l'a vu s'enfuir du coup
et monter dans une voiture de sport rouge,
et prendre la fuite avec cette voiture.
L'aprem, Martin a foncé voir la police pour leur expliquer ce qu'il venait de se passer
Et en fait, ils lui ont dit que c'était juste un gars qui l'avait repéré quelque part
et qui l'avait suivi jusqu'à son domicile, dans le but de... on sait pas.
On peut imaginer tout ce qu'on veux mais je trouve quand même que
quand un mec te regarde dormir à ton insu, et ensuite toque, et ensuite ouvre la fenêtre
et rentre chez toi par effraction
Il est pas méga bien intentionné !
À l'heure actuelle, Martin a emménagé, il habite plus au même endroit suite a cette histoire
et il sait toujours pas qui était cette personne,
et qu'est ce qu'elle allait faire, voir LUI faire.
Donc on remercie Mike ! *Bruit d'applaudissements*  On applaudit tous Mike
et on espère tous avoir un Mike qui habite au-dessus de chez nous
Okay ! Okay ! Voilà, petite mise en bouche, elle est pas mal...
AHHHHH! J'aime pas ce délire de gens
qui te regardent, qui te stalk et qui veulent
rentrer chez toi là, putain c'est horrible !
2ème histoire ! Qui est différente de celle-ci.
S'il y a des parents qui regardent cette vidéo, qui ont des enfants ou des gens qui s'occupent d'enfants dans
des centres aérés, j'en sais rien,
vous allez vraiment, vraiment bader !
Même moi qui suis pas très sensible normalement à ça, ça me met mal !
*Musique de suspense*
C'est l'histoire de Lucie, mère de deux enfants :
un fils de de cinq ans et une fille de cinq ans et demi,
qui décide, à un après midi, comme des tas de parents partout dans le monde, d'aller au parc avec eux
Pour qu'ils jouent, qu'ils fassent du toboggan, qu'ils s'amusent, tout ce qu'il y a de plus normal
Elle explique qu'elle doit rejoindre, là-bas, une amie à elle qui est venue avec sa fille
Là on parle pas d'une petite aire de jeux comme il y a dans pleins de parcs partout en France
On parle d'une grosse, grosse aire de jeux, avec un gros parking, à côté il y a une forêt.
Bref, Lucie arrive au parc et elle retrouve sa copine,
elle explique, qu'en plus de son amie, il y a aussi une autre maman qui est là avec ses deux enfants qu'elle connait bien,
et la seule personne qu'elle connait pas, c'est un père de famille, qui est là avec des deux enfants :
une fille de dix ans et un garçon de douze ans
mais il a pas du tout l'air bizarre donc pour le moment aucun danger à signaler
Tout le monde est assis, les mamans discutent entre elles, tout le monde discute...
Voilà c'est bon enfant, c'est cool, bonne ambiance, ambiance de famille...
Les enfants s'éloignent un peu des parents, ils commencent à faire leur vie au milieu de l'aire de jeux,
faire du toboggan, etc...
Et le fils de Lucie veut faire de la balançoire, sauf qu'à cet âge-là, pour faire de la balançoire, faut être deux
Faut que t'aies quelqu'un qui te pousse, mais son fils, bah y a personne pour en faire avec lui,
donc il est seul tout.
Lucie du coup en tant que maman extraordinaire se lève pour aller faire de la balançoire avec son fils
et là, il y a le garçon de dix ans,
qui est donc le fils du mec qu'elle connait pas,
qui est au parc avec son fils et sa fille,
qui vient la voir et qui lui dit mot pour mot : "Salut, est-ce que tu veux que je joue avec lui ?"
Lucie trouve ça un peu bizarre au premier abord
étant donné qu'il a demandé à elle et pas directement à son fils.
Ce qui est un peu bizarre...
Mais elle lui dit : "Vas-y, okay, va jouer avec lui, amusez-vous bien"
Il rejoint donc le fils de Lucie, et il commence à faire de la balançoire avec lui
et Lucie retourne se rasseoir, et tout se passe bien dans le meilleur des mondes.
Pour le moment ! (voix aigüe)
Lucie, elle reste un peu étonnée de ce qui vient de se passer,
parce qu'elle dit que le gamin, il avait une voix vraiment plate, il souriait pas, pas de ton, d’intonation,
et une fois qu'il a rejoint son fils pour jouer, il lui parlait pas, ils se parlaient pas du tout.
Mais bon !
Son fils joue avec lui et passe un bon moment donc Lucie, elle est contente hein.
Après plusieurs minutes, Lucie, elle retourne sur le banc,
donc au milieu des autres parents
et elle entend le petit garçon de dix ans parler à son fils, donc ça y est ils se mettent enfin à parler
donc elle se dit, bon bah okay, c'est peut-être juste qu'il est timide avec les adultes.
Le père de cet enfant de 10 ans se dirige vers sa voiture,
ce qui le rapproche de Lucie, et elle lui dit qu'elle a trouvé ça trop mignon que son petit garçon lui ai proposé à elle
de jouer avec son fils et pas directement à son fils, sauf que le mec en face répond que c'est pas son fils
Il lui dit : "C'est pas du tout mon fils", il lui dit même plus ! *Musique angoissante*
Il lui dit qu'il sait pas qui c'est, qu'il y a vingt minutes il est venu le voir et qu'il lui a proposé de jouer avec sa fille
et, qu'entre-temps, il les a suivi jusqu'au parc.
QUI ! EST ! CE ! GAMIN !
Lucie, instinct de maman, comprend qu'il y a un truc qui va pas et que c'est très bizarre comme situation,
et elle regarde vers la balançoire et surprise !
Son fils n'est plus là !
Et le petit garçon qui n'appartient à personne non plus.  *Musique angoissante*
C'est Horrible !
Lucie se lève, elle confie sa fille à son amie et elle court vers la balançoire en hurlant le nom de son fils.
Après avoir pas mal couru, elle les voit au niveau de l'entrée de la forêt,
sachant qu'elle précise que les arbres, donc l'entrée de la forêt sont vraiment loin de l'aire des jeux.
Son fils se retourne vers elle, commence à essayer de marcher vers elle, et là, le petit garçon
lui attrape le bras et le tire vers la forêt.
Sauf que ! Lucie, elle explique que son fils, il aime pas du tout être poussé ou attrapé ou tiré
et que quand ça lui arrive, il se met vraiment en colère et devient agressif
et elle explique que c'est le seul jour où elle a été reconnaissante de ça,
parce que, en fait, son fils, du coup, s'est vraiment énervé
et a commencé à lui mettre des coups de tête, à le frapper, pour qu'il le lâche quoi.
Lucie, étant maintenant plus ou moins proche des deux garçons, le petit garçon mystérieux lâche le fils de Lucie
et s'enfuit dans la forêt, et Lucie peut enfin atteindre son fils et le prendre dans les bras et pleurer ses morts
parce qu'elle a eu la peur de sa vie.
Ils retournent tout les deux à l'aire de jeux.
Les amis de Lucie, entre-temps, ont compris qu'il s'était passer un truc bizarre, etc...
Et Lucie demande du coup à son fils : "Pourquoi tu l'a suivi ? pourquoi vous êtes allés là-bas ? qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il t'a dit ?"
Son fils lui explique alors que l'autre petit garçon voulait l'emmener aller voir Ryan
Ryan, c'est une chaine Youtube pour enfants, où en gros c'est un gosse qui ouvre des jouets,
qui s'appelle Ryan ToysReview.
Et c'est apparemment la chaine Youtube préférée du fils de Lucie et il arrête pas d'en parler,
et du coup l'autre gamin a utilisé ça pour attirer le fils de Lucie
vers la forêt en disant : "Hey je sais où Ryan habite, viens on va le voir tout les deux
c'est par là, suis moi !"
Vu le jeune âge, du coup, et la naïveté du fils de Lucie,
bah il a dit : "Okay, let's go, vas-y, on va pouvoir jouer avec Ryan c'est génial" et il l'a suivi.
Comme pour la première histoire, ça finit bien.
Mais du coup, on ne sait pas qu'elles étaient les intentions de ces gens en fait.
En l'occurrence, le gamin, on ne sait pas du tout ce qu'il voulait, on ne sait pas du tout ce qu'il allait faire
On sait pas du tout si c'était juste un gamin dérangé qui agissait seul,
ou s'il était dans l'emprise d'un réseau de gens qui kidnappent des enfants.
et que, ce réseau utilisait ce gamin pour attirer des enfants vers la forêt, vers eux.
On sait pas, on a aucune réponse à ces questions-là
Bref, mystère non élucidé !
Et je pense à un bon gros traumatisme pour Lucie,
qui ne laissera plus JAMAIS son gosse avec des enfants qu'elle connait pas,
ou qui ont des parents qu'elle connait pas quoi.
Bref, ça me ...
Voilà, moi qui voulait déjà pas trop d'enfants, ça retarde de dix ans le moment où j'en aurais.
Je ne veux pas avoir ces angoisses-là de daron,
j'ai mes angoisses de jeune adulte, ça suffit. Okay ?
La dernière histoire, mais elle est HORRIBLE !
Parce que je m'identifie pas mal à celle-là, parce...
Vous, vous allez comprendre, je vais vous expliquer
Alors, voici l'histoire de Mélanie.
*Musique de suspense *
Mélanie explique, qu'après avoir vécu plus de cinq ans dans son appartement,
elle s'est mise à remarquer que des choses n'étaient plus à leur place chez elle, quand elle rentrait du travail.
On parle pas d'objets qui ont bougé, genre ah je pensais avoir mis le tournevis dans le placard,
et il est sur la table de la cuisine.
On parle de trucs qui ont pas trop de sens.
Par exemple, vous savez les fameux étuis à couteaux,
dans lesquels on met les couteaux de cuisine qui tranche beaucoup,
Et ben, les couteaux étaient mis dans l'autre sens
et du coup ils bloquaient, ils rentraient pas bien dedans
Meilleur exemple : dans son dressing, donc, elle a des fringues suspendues,
et des fois, elle rentrait et les fringues étaient suspendues dans l'AUTRE sens.
Pleins de petits trucs comme ça, mis bout à bout, où en voyant ça, elle s'est dit :
"Il y a un truc qui cloche, qui est pas normal."
Mais tu sais, t'as pas vraiment de preuves pour appuyer ce que tu dis,
et ça pourrait très bien être juste elle, qui est distraite lorsqu'elle remet,
par exemple, sa robe dans son dressing, ou lorsqu'elle remet son couteau de cuisine dans l'étui.
Et c'est là où je m'identifie beaucoup à cette histoire,
c'est qu'il y a pleins de moments chez soi, où on fait des trucs par automatisme.
Typiquement, ranger sa veste dans son dressing, on le fait complètement par automatisme, vu que c'est la 500e fois qu'on le fait.
Ranger un couteau à un endroit pareil, enfin tout ce genre d'actions qu'on fait toute la semaine, tous les jours :
on finit par les faire vraiment automatiquement, et du coup tu te souviens même pas de quand tu l'as fait,
mais tu sais que tu l'as fait. Et donc là, elle se dit :
"Bon ben si ça se trouve, c'est moi quand j'étais passée en mode automatique et que j'ai rangé mon truc,
je l'ai mis dans le mauvais sens et je m'en suis pas rendue compte", ça peut arriver.
Et ça m'arrive, moi par exemple, tout le temps.
Elle explique qu'après plusieurs mois de trucs déplacés au hasard comme ça, de petits détails,
qui font qu'elle a le sentiment bizarre et qu'elle se sent pas bien et qu'elle devient un petit peu parano,
les choses ont arrêté de bouger, d'un coup. Mais ça c'était deux semaines avant qu'elle écrive son histoire.
Entre-temps, il s'est passé pas mal de choses, ça peut vous paraitre débile ce qu'elle dit, mais moi je comprend un peu.
Quand elle rentrait chez elle, son chat, il lui miaulait dessus vénère,
un chat, c'est vraiment pas con, comme pour lui indiquer qu'un truc s'était passé et qui était un peu anormal,
et ça attire son attention, elle se dit : "Tiens, c'est inhabituel."
Les jours passent et un jour, Mélanie, elle rentre chez elle et elle trouve une paire de chaussettes par terre,
qui ne lui appartient pas
Je précise que Mélanie ne vit pas avec son mec
Le lendemain soir, son petit ami vient dormir chez elle et elle lui montre la paire de chaussettes,
en lui disant : "Hé c'est sûrement à toi, t'as dû les oublier la dernière fois."
Et son petit ami lui dit : "Non, non, c'est vraiment pas à moi."  *Bruit angoissant*
(rires)
Badant ! À partir de là, Mélanie et son copain comprennent qu'il y a possiblement quelqu'un qui a les clés,
ou qui a accès, en tout cas, à l'appartement de Mélanie et qui va chez elle.
Et enfin ! Le dernier truc qui a été le déclic, où là ils ont décidé d'agir, Mélanie et son copain,
ça s'est produit la veille au soir du moment où elle écrit ce texte et elle explique que :
elle est allée diner avec son copain. Après diner, ils se sont dirigés vers chez elle pour finir la soirée,
et en arrivant devant chez elle, elle a mis sa clé dans sa porte pour la déverrouiller et surprise...*Bruit de suspense*
la porte était pas verrouillée.
ça peut vous paraitre anecdotique, sauf que Mélanie explique qu'elle a un TOC avec ça,
et moi, je connais des gens qui ont le même TOC, où, en fait, à chaque fois qu'elle part de chez elle,
elle verrouille la porte et elle vérifie 3-4 fois qu'elle a bien verrouillé la porte de chez elle.
Tous ceux qui connaissent Mélanie savent qu'elle a ce TOC-là, puisqu'elle le fait même avec ses amis.
Genre quand elle va chez un ami et qu'il part de chez lui,
elle vérifie 3-4 fois que son ami a bien fermé la porte de chez lui à double tour.
Donc c'est un vrai TOC vénère, et là le fait qu'elle rentre et que la porte soit pas fermée à clé,
elle a tout de suite compris que quelqu'un était venu. Voilà c'est impossible que ce soit un oubli,
il y a quelqu'un qui est venu chez elle. Elle en est maintenant persuadée.
Son copain, qui la connait bien, comprend aussi la situation et comprend lui aussi
que quelqu'un est venu chez sa meuf. Ils se précipitent alors tous les deux dans la maison
pour voir s'il y a pas quelqu'un qui est encore là, pour voir s'il y a pas des objets qui ont bougé de place.
Et là, son mec se met à vérifier les ouvertures, donc les fenêtres, la porte coulissante, tout ça
Et bingo, il y a une porte coulissante dans le salon et elle est ouverte. *Bruit angoissant*
Sauf que Mélanie ne laisse jamais cette porte ouverte, ça confirme alors tout ce qu'elle pensait
à propos des objets qui bougent de place chez elle, qu'elle est pas folle.
Bref, quelqu'un est venu chez elle et  elle veut savoir qui. *Musique angoissante*
Ce que je viens de vous raconter là, le truc de la porte d'entrée, ça s'est passé la veille
au moment où elle écrit  ce texte. Quoi qu'il en soit, elle explique que, du coup,
elle a commandé des caméras de sécurité, qu'elle va mettre chez elle,
et qu'elle hésite à appeler la police, et elle  demande aux gens des conseils en fait,
de lui dire : "Putain qu'est ce que je dois faire quoi ?"
C'est assez intéressant , parce que, pour celui-là, j'ai beaucoup lu l'espace commentaire
et il y a pas mal de gens qui lui ont dit : "Mais change tout de suite ta serrure, n'hésite pas, fonce,
ça prend une journée et let's go, tu vois, tu seras beaucoup plus en sécurité dans ta tête et en vrai."
Sauf que Mélanie, elle est locataire et que pour changer sa serrure, elle doit appeler son proprio,
et du coup, ça va mettre beaucoup plus de temps qu'une journée.
Et en commentaire, il y a une réponse vachement intéressante d'une fille,
qui explique qu'il lui est arrivé exactement la même chose il y a 16 ans.
Elle avait un appartement pareil, elle était en location, elle était pas propriétaire
et elle remarquait tout le temps, quand elle rentrait chez elle, que des objets avaient bougé,
elle retrouvait des fringues par terre, elle retrouvait son make-up  pas rangé comme elle, elle le rangeait.
Et donc, cette fille, dans le commentaire, explique que l'élément déclencheur qu'elle a eu,
cette personne-là, elle, sur son bureau, range ses papiers d'une manière très précise.
C'est un truc qu'elle fait depuis des années, c'est un TOC qu'elle a,
ça l'aide à se sentir bien, elle le fait tac, tac, tac.
Un jour, elle est rentrée, il y a plus que deux papiers qui étaient pas au bon endroit,
et c'est là où elle a vraiment compris, elle s'est dit : "C'est impossible que ça vienne de moi,
il y a forcément quelqu'un qui vient."  Sauf que là, on a la suite de l'histoire, parce que c'était il y a 16 ans.
La meuf a installé des caméras de sécurité chez elle, et bingo, les jours passent, et en fait, elle découvre, un jour,
dans les rushs des caméras, que c'est la propriétaire de son appart, qui vient chez elle,
et qui essaie des tenues à elle, qui se maquille avec son make-up, qui utilisait ses affaires, etc...
Et c'est absolument HORRIBLE ! HORRIBLE !
Elle est donc allée voir la police avec ces images, sauf qu'entre-temps, la propriétaire a vu les caméras,
et donc, elle savait qu'elle s'était faite grillée, et du coup elle a entamé des démarches contre cette locataire
pour la faire virer, pour pas qu'elle se retrouve, elle, dans la merde devant le tribunal,
parce que ce qu'elle fait, c'est parfaitement illégal et HORRIBLE !
Voilà ! Ça me fait bader, parce que, maintenant, quand je vais arriver chez moi
et qu'il y a un truc qui sera pas à l'endroit, où je pense l'avoir mis, je vais me dire : "Attend,
mais regarde Mélanie, ce qu'il lui est arrivé, si ça se trouve, je l'avais vraiment pas mis là
et je suis entrain de me convaincre, que c'est moi qui ai dû le faire en mode étourdi, qui ai dû le mettre ailleurs,
mais si ça se trouve, je l'avais vraiment pas mis là et QUELQU'UN EST VENU CHEZ MOI !  (hausse la voix)
(rires)
Allez ! C'est la FIN de cette vidéo. Trois histoires d'horreur. J'espère qu'elle vous a plu,
ça faisait un petit moment, je les trouve vraiment chouettes, ces histoires-là. Ne soyez pas paranos,
Si vous pensez que vos affaires ont bougé quand vous rentrez chez vous, c'est probablement VOUS, en réalité,
qui les avez mis à un autre endroit et qui êtes convaincus de les avoir mis à l'endroit habituel.
Je vous dis à bientôt, j'espère que ça vous a plus, j'espère que j'ai raconté ça comme il faut,
j'espère que tout est clair et n'hésitez pas à débattre sur tout ça dans les commentaires.
Et pourquoi pas raconter des trucs qui vous sont arrivés, dans le même genre. N'inventez rien !
Profitons de ces vidéos-là, pour que l'espace commentaires devienne un espace,
où tout le monde raconte un peu ses expériences, du genre. Voilà.
Je vous dis à bientôt. Voilà. Boite à meuh, droite the meuh. *Bruit de boite à meuh*
*Bruit de coup*